my name is Alex I work here at Bloomberg
where I've worked it for about two and a
half years having graduated with the
degree in mathematics but I am a
software engineer here at remote so my
role is to make a software deploy and
deploying software is a big part of that
so just so I sort of know how many
people would consider themselves state
scientists software engineers academics
okay cool awesome I thought it would be
ma Scott so yeah as I said I worked at
blue mo for about two and a half years
where I've been a member of the
commodity East London team specifically
for this talk talk about our work in the
European power and gas sector where I've
contributed to the models but more
importantly again for this talk is I've
contributed to the infrastructure around
the models and the user interface as
well and so what I want to sort of
explore here is that modeling is a small
part of what we do it's a very small
part of what makes an entire product and
that your model needs to be able to fit
into the wider world the wider system in
order for your customers to actually use
it or feel you know whoever wants to use
that model to actually benefit from it
cool so I'll start with a little bit
about Bloomberg what we do and how we
use PI data technology specifically
within my team and then we'll get on to
the interesting stuff about what we
actually deploy so Bloomberg is what a
big company we've got about three and a
half thousand developers which means
that we have a big range of experiences
and a big range of technologies to go
with that one of which of course is
Python so pythons gaining momentum it's
being used more and more and more at
Bloomberg for reasons I'm sure you're
all aware of and we'll just discuss a
specific example where python is worked
for us better than C++
which is one of the the big languages
that's in use here at Bloomberg we have
a proprietary build of Python that gives
us access to our proprietary libraries
and one of the big things that again I'm
going to talk about later on is that it
gives us access to our service-oriented
architecture and our core database
technologies so we use a range of
databases and some of the libraries that
we use for those are proprietary to
Bloomberg and or commercial as well and
we have to be able to link those into
Python in order to use them so
commodities London Rd there's about
there's ten of us in the tea now I think
and we have bought a wide range of
responsibilities one of which is
solution for European power and gas
traders we have a sister team out in New
York who looks after us guys as well and
what they're really interested in is
supposed especially in the modeling
space is the balance between supply and
want so the balance between how much
electricity there is or how much gas
there is and how much people will
actually want to use it cool so there's
various models at play here so supply of
electricity is if this day and ages
varies on wind and solar and things like
that
the demand for power is very very much
driven by the weather and in the UK the
demand for gas is very much driven by
heating and obviously if it's cold
outside you probably want your heating
on inside and so all these things come
into play one thing I'm not going to
talk about today with but contribute to
a large part of our products on the
supply side is the power plant outage
data which is is really important to our
product so you know actually going out
and finding out which power plants are
down and the splined of our models so
the splines of and what disease is where
we're going to focus our effort
and I'll go into a little bit more
detail about that now so how do we use
PI data at Bloomberg commodities London
and long title anyway so one of our big
functions and I'll go into a bit more
detail about what this looks like is the
European market models function so one
of the things it does is display low
latency weather updates from WSI weather
services international famous for
weather calm and very focus in the
industry as a good source of your
weather we have supply and demand models
for the major markets so we have wind
supply models we have solar supply
models we have power demand models
custom are models for markets such as UK
in Germany and the most important thing
here is we use numpy pandas scipy
matplotlib
bunch of other stuff in our pipeline in
our workflows to enable us to do that so
a little sort of aside I want to take
here is is to talk about why we started
using Python so when we started on this
product is actually before I joined
bluebird well the first model was the
the team developed was wind supply model
for the UK this was developed by the
modelers offline using MATLAB and our
two technologies that one we don't want
to deploy its production license fees
and or can't can't deploy to production
for various reasons there are also
technologies that we as software
engineers aren't comfortable with and
we're the ones that have to get up at
two o'clock in the morning to fix the
issue that's gone wrong in production
and if we don't understand the
technology that's going to be very hard
to do so
enter c++ we take the model that the
modelers made
convert it over to C++ and of course it
doesn't work it didn't really have much
relation to the original model and a lot
of time was spent actually getting the
two models to agree a lot of time spent
compiling stuff and things you just
don't want to do when you're developing
a model so the next time a modeling task
came up we looked Python so we're a few
models in now and we're going to talk a
bit more about the power demand models
today so the power demand model in eum
is a multi-stage regression model it
incorporates the weather data as I said
from WSI so this is an example where you
have to fit into the wider system
something else is is responsible for
getting that data into the system it has
a strong auto regressive component and
strong seasonal trends and the model
runs both on desktop and production so
this is where some of the software
engineering comes into play
so our modelers used s thoughts very
similar to the ones you're sitting
infront of today the windows-based they
are not connected to our production
systems for obvious reasons you can have
occasional read access but certainly no
write access or anything like that which
is the complete opposite to our
production systems so our production
systems obviously running out in our
production database datacenters
they've got connectivity to all our
production databases production services
and more specifically they have to write
to them as well now this is obviously
two very different environments that we
want the model to work in because we
want to be able to run the same model
both in development and in production so
that we know that we're running exactly
the same thing all times so this is just
a brief overview of the other side of
the coin how we actually present this
data to our clients so this is the
UK power market that we currently have
so you can see that you can display the
raw weather on the far left there when
supply embedded wind supply which is
like the wind that people use in their
own homes so if you have a wind mill in
your back garden it actually has the
effect of reducing your demand rather
than increasing the wind supply on the
network so it's subtly different model
solar supply and power demand and you've
got all the the sort of the basics they
you can see what the power demand is but
again you need to understand the
business aspect here in order to be able
to design a reasonable UI so we have
power and gas traders who are interested
in trading today or trading tomorrow
they might be interested in looking at
the two Dave you with half hourly
granularity the opposite end of the
spectrum is people that want to trade
next week they're trading whole days or
whole Peaks so like 8 a.m. to 8 p.m.
each day something like that they might
be interested in seeing a 15 day view
with 6 hourly granularity or 3 hour ago
something like that and this is what I
would call the programmers view because
only programmers want to see 15 days
about half hour so it just gives you a
brief overview and we've also got a few
summaries around so that if you don't
trade a particular market but it moves
quickly the estimates move a lot then
you can see that on the bottom er so
this we're nearly at the end of the
Bloomberg bit so what I wanted to just
highlight with these sort of real-world
examples was the the model although we
we maintain the models we also have to
maintain a much larger system we have to
maintain numerous databases that hold
numerous different bits of data that
actually go into the model including
whether we have to maintain a bunch of
middleware
yeah we've got systems teams and
infrastructure teams that provide us
with service-oriented architecture
libraries and and maintain our
underlying databases for us but yeah we
have to develop that middleware to
connect it all together as well as the
model itself and we have to develop the
UI as well yeah it's all well and good
have this model that runs on our
desktops but we can't send that to all
of our clients so you know we have to
have some way of presenting that data to
them and it has to be useful too
you know it has to be it has to fit
their workflow can't fit our model it
can't be the most convenient way for us
to display the data has to display the
data in the way that they actually need
it so how do we go about engineering a
model and I chose engineering quite
carefully because this isn't and I want
to talk about how we go from a model you
might chuck together on your laptop
through to the model that you can
actually use out in the real world in in
production so I hope everyone can see
most of that so what does a laptop model
would look like and really what do I
mean by that I simply mean a model that
sort of running on your laptop running
on your desktop it doesn't really
connect to anywhere you've gone you've
gone and found some data somewhere you
know you you found whatever old data
that you could find you may not even
check that you can legally use that data
at this stage but that is quite
important when it comes to going to
production you have used you know you've
good at what you do you've used your
experience to split the training data
away from the test data you know that
you probably should split the training
stage from the forecasting stage and at
this point I like to say something I
missed earlier that with most of our
models or regression models because like
this is a regression model example but
obviously you could probably apply it to
classification models as well
everything goes around in memory you
calculate the errors you display the
areas you pause to display some pretty
graphs these are all awesome things when
you're modeling and what I'd like to say
at this point is that this is an
essential part of model development you
know model development it's a creative
art and as we've said in one of the last
talks it's really using the human
experience of of the market of the
physical phenomenon that you're trying
to model to sort of guide a computer on
how they might do it for us
you know you shouldn't be constrained by
software engineering considerations at
that point but once the model fits you
know the hard work actually has to begin
of actually deploying it and you know in
our case you know selling it to our
client so that nice little laptop model
that we have before needs to become
something that looks kind of like this
okay so again this is kind of a generic
model but it's kind of based on our
power demand stuff so the energy markets
around the world are always changing and
the model trained six months ago a year
ago six weeks ago could be completely
irrelevant to the market as it is now
yeah the amount of embedded wind the
amount of solar panels then you know
even the amount of production coming
from a given wind farm if it's in
development could be changing and it
changes very quickly you know if someone
turns on a wind turbine in a field of
five or six winter wise you increase
that capacity by 20% and that's quite
significant thing that you need to
capture very quickly and so you have to
retrain the model on a regular basis so
here we've we've divided the training
phase around from the forecast phase and
for us we actually run our training
phases in production
calibration phases whatever you want to
call and we run them on a regular basis
and for ease of ease of simplicity and
making sure that we all know what's
going on we tend to run them a every day
early in the morning
so then here we we now move on to sort
of the data side of things so instead of
having that nice file that you curated
from all around the Internet
well our production system doesn't have
access to the Internet you can't just go
and grab stuff from the Internet
production how do you know you're
getting genuine stuff back there are
obviously ways of dealing with that but
it's probably some one else's problem to
onboard all your data yeah and it could
be many different teams that do that you
can end up with many different databases
that you need so we might have a
service-oriented architecture around
that but you're gonna have to have some
sort of phase for bringing that all
together and actually coercing it into
the form that your file took that was
sitting on your your disk the training
data in memory was probably going to
look kind of like the the file and then
you can reuse your regression training
from before and to actually run that
regression training as you did on your
laptop but before we just created this
model we analyzed it you know we
character lated errors displayed graphs
maybe try to interpret some of the
parameters but maybe we didn't bother
saving it you know we don't need it
again but in our world we do need it
again we run this forecasting
approximately 12 times a day so again
the way that the the weather systems
around the world work is that there's
two major global weather providers GFS
and ECMWF GFS the global forecast system
coming out the state's ECMWF the
european center for medium-term weather
forecasting based up in reading and
basically are the own youtube organ
producing global weather forecasts
around the world they get funneled
through WSI and then they arrive at us
GFS arrives four times a day
ICI run arrives two times a day and they
each have two variations they have a
deterministic run which basically gives
you one forecast and they have an
ensemble run which basically gives you
20 to 50 different forecasts of what
could happen in different situations and
we have to run the model over and over
again so that's 12 different model runs
that we have to do over and over again
but actually it's more than that because
the more the weather itself arise
point-by-point so when it first arrives
we've just got one time stunt and then a
minute later we'll get the next one a
minute later we'll get the next one so
actually we have to feed to those 12
forecast runs we actually have to run
the forecast 20 to 80 times depending on
which forecast we're looking at oh and
by the way the granularities of the
different forecasts are all different as
well as you have to deal with that as
well so these are things that you have
to sort of take into account in your
model and something that you know you'd
separate into another forecast phases as
I've called it here you can probably
reuse some of the training data fa
gather the training data to gather your
input data but you need to make sure
it's actually the future looking data
rather than historic looking data and
then we can obviously this is where we
can reuse the regression forecast stuff
from the laptop model laptop model to
get our regression results obviously
here we don't have the observations that
we want to compare it to so we can't
calculate errors at this point can't
display pretty graphs because well
there's nobody on the production server
to look at them anyway well I've been
talking to you long ago so we actually
have to go and save it so you have to
save it into a game for your service
probably a database but then you have to
kick off the next part of the system
so the next part of the system has to
start doing its work you have to start
kicking the middleware into into got to
push it down to the user interface on
the web that could be some sort of
WebSocket thing or
for us it's a bunch of technologies we
use in-house to top they are all
terminal software that you see running
on on the PC so you probably then still
want to evaluate those errands still
want to display those graphs but that's
probably something you keep down the
road do on a weekly basis monthly basis
to evaluate how your models are going
cool and so the only thing I'd like to
say at this point is that we run out all
these models on a cluster of machines so
not only are you considering what
happens on one machine we have a cluster
of machines to worry about so when we
run them it sorry when we run a model it
could run on any number of machines and
they need to all of those machines need
to have access to the regression model
they need to have access to all of the
data they need to have access to being
able to save it and all of these things
are things that could potentially be
problematic and again we'll come back to
that in a bit so some of the productive
production considerations that I'd like
to highlight so data needs to be cleaned
throughout the onboarding process yeah
that could be by external vendors so for
us it could be WSI you kindly removed
bias from from forecasts you know if you
look at some of the other talks like TF
Elle's API that I saw earlier
you know maybe they clean some of the
data down so that it's it's more
reliable it needs to be automated and
consistent know if anybody's ever gone
through a file and looked at it and well
that value looks a bit funny got rid of
it that doesn't work in production
unless you want to be available at 3
o'clock in the morning when the model
actually wants to train it train itself
that that simply can't work you know you
have to be able to teach the model to
remove these dodgy data points itself it
needs to be reliable it can't sometimes
work and sometimes not work
sometimes converge and sometimes not
converge and that's probably a sign of a
bad model yeah it has to be able to
reliably train it has to be able to
reliably run it run its full course it
has to be resilient it has to be
resilient to missing data to dodgy data
points resilient to service failures
resilient to machine failures all these
things that when if it when it goes
wrong in your laptop you just rerun the
model we can't do that in production to
a certain extent and one of the big ones
that ironically I forgot is the ability
to backfill results so this is a big
problem for us actually we need to show
our clients what the model would have
predicted had we had it in the past so
if we're trying to sell our client a
model in in the late summer they want to
know how it's actually going to perform
over the coming winter you know how
would it have performed last winter had
you had that model so you need to be
able to get the data as if it was then
so you need to have the actuals as if
you're in the past you need to have the
weather forecasters if you're in the
past you have to be able to run the
model as if you're in the past you have
to be able to save the model as if
you're in the past and these things all
seem reasonably easy to do until you
consider how often you just get the
current system time or just request the
latest forecast from your service or you
know you've just just saved the model
but don't actually tell it what data you
use to run it from so these are all
things that we've got to consider and
it's often something that is is that
I've seen this is forgotten and it's
quite important you also need to
consider what data is available when so
you know is all the data that you've
been training on actually available in
advance so obviously the observed
weather
actuals aren't available in advance we
don't know what the temperature is is
actually going to be in the future but
we've got forecasts of that are there
forecasts for your other data members
are there or are they published in
advance yeah maybe you're using some
dummy variables as an indication of
something that might happen in advance
cool so and then you also consider how
does it actually run 24 hours a day
seven days a week so this cluster of
machines is used by many models soon to
be used by many teams as well and we we
need to balance the load across the
entire cluster you don't have to worry
about that on your laptop you're the
only person using it you know you person
inputting jobs and the only thing
actually going on for that it's not
reality in production so we need Aloe
ballots that actually distributes the
jobs we need a process monitor that
takes the jobs actually runs the model
and says okay have you actually started
did you actually finish did you save
your results successfully did you model
the result successful poorly any other
way around and then what happens if it
doesn't work you could try just really
running it but that probably won't work
either so you probably need to raise the
alarm and I think this is probably one
of the most important points I'm going
to make is about raising the alarm so
you need to make a decision about
okay so models failed how do I actually
tell someone about that do I send them
an email do I send them a text do I use
one of these nifty phone api's to phone
them up and say hey and what has failed
but if you know as I said before we run
ours 80 times in a given model run if a
single point fails on a run probably not
that big a deal it can be dealt with on
Monday morning it can be dealt with once
you've you finished that
project that it's got this deadline this
week it can probably wait a little bit
if the entire model runs failed or the
same model is consistently failing over
and over again then it's probably
something wrong with the model you
probably actually need to need to look
at it you know the program is involved
actually need to come on and debug the
situation but if all the models have
failed on all the points then that's
probably nothing to do with the models
at all
maybe the networks down maybe we've got
a bad machine and we just need to shut
that machine off from the cluster repair
it before print it back on maybe some
part the infrastructure is not quite
working yeah if you lost a service if
you if you lost the networks have you
lost your databases if you lost a data
center all of these things I don't need
to be rung up about someone else needs
to be online and that's not because I
don't want to be rung up and fine you
can ring me up but it's just added delay
to fixing the problem it's more delay to
our clients from seeing good model runs
and obviously that's something that we'd
like to avoid we'd like to get the right
people on the job as quickly as possible
and this is where sis hat means and
operators come in so the people that
actually you know can see all these
alarms coming in they can make a
decision about what's actually going on
they can see that the networks have gone
down machines are bad services aren't up
they can make an intelligent decision
about whether it's a ring you or not you
know maybe there's a note on your on
your phone book page saying ring
somebody else this week I'm not
available and obviously some of that
could probably be automated and some of
it is automated in our case but a lot of
it can't be a lot of it you need a human
to actually make a decision or at least
that's the easiest way to do you think
so to conclude and I think I'm running
about on time a good model decent data
clean data is essential
what'd you do on your laptop what'd you
do to prototype how you go about
discovering your model it sent your work
but it's only step one you know once
you've got that model if you want to run
it on a regular basis if you want to to
sell that sell the results you need to
have a plan to defer actually deploying
it you know it needs to run efficiently
it needs to be quick enough you if if
our models took more than a minute or so
to run the next point of being and we'd
be running overlaps and that would be a
bad thing and it needs to be reliable
you know it needs to deal with a noisy
input you can't deal with the noisy
input on its behalf
you know you need to it needs to be able
to do to do that and with that as
anybody got any questions questions for
Alex
don't you be able to repeat the question
yes so the question was once the models
developed how long does it actually take
to deploy unfortunately that varies so
much it's kind of hard to say you know
if we wanted a new country added to
power demand that probably be a lot
quicker because a lot of the
infrastructures and we're you there that
we can reuse then if we're gonna use a
whole new model again some of the
infrastructure would obviously be reused
it's been designed for that but but
maybe there's more tweaks that needs to
be made so it can be it can vary quite a
lot so we're we're all R&D I'm a
software engineer I work in R&D that's
just what we call it so do you actually
abstract that building or is it
basically a case of rewriting and extend
that more widely do you have anything
else I think the short answer is
probably yes
so yes files are very similar to the
databases and certainly in the newer
models power demand that abstraction is
is very obvious and we're looking to
reuse that in the future
so yes abstract the files abstract the
i/o away from the model is as it were
the problem comes when you don't not you
don't consider or it's not obvious where
the line is so some of your your laptop
model it might be a single file might be
a single file that's got all the feature
set on production some of that feature
set might be in a file that might be a
modeler supplied file it might have some
sort of dummy data that characterize
dates or something like that
another part of that file could come
from a database could come for the
weather services another part of it
could come from another database so
actually the i/o on production is much
more complex you've actually got to go
to multiple places and bring it all
together now as you say if we've
actually abstracted it correctly that
should be relatively easy to do the
problem is when you're taking a new
model from sort of the development stage
to the production stage where that
abstraction hasn't been made or
assumptions about the abstraction have
been made which are possibly hard to
port over to reality which makes it more
difficult do we abstract anything else
not really I guess I cannot not I can't
think of anything particularly obvious
but I would flip the question slightly
about things that you don't really need
to consider as a modeler you don't
really need to consider that it's
running our cluster because that's how
that that's handled outside of the model
we we just that's all done in C++ in our
case and you know we just run the model
as as Python code so that sort of done
outside the model so you don't need to
kind of worry about that but you need to
be aware that these clusters are busy
and they they've got to run lots of
models at the same time thank you very
much Alex